[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat 90
minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et aussi
le sommaire de ce 14 mars c'est l'heure
des dernières tractations des coups de
fil au députés LR hésitant des choix
stratégiques à faire à l'Assemblée jeudi
pour voter la réforme des retraites
passer par le 49-3 en attendant le
gouvernement Martel encore et toujours
l'argument de l'équilibre budgétaire si
le député finalement ce que vous
nous prive faire la baisse des retraites
ou la faillite du pays nous nous avons
fait le choix de la responsabilité dans
notre premier débat on va décortiquer
ensemble les enjeux des deux prochains
jours notamment pour Elisabeth borne et
puis on revient au format plus classique
de sens public avec une seconde partie
volontairement décalée de l'actualité du
jour je vous propose un gros plan sur le
réseau social préféré des enfants et des
jeunes Tik Tok un géant chinois
soupçonné d'espionnage de leviers
d'influence et même de laver le cerveau
de toute une génération d'occidentaux
faut-il interdire Tik Tok réponse dans
45 minutes mais d'abord trois lettres
que le grand public découvre c'est MP
pour commission mixte paritaire Samia
déchire nous en détail les enjeux
le sort de la réforme des retraites est
désormais entre les mains d'une poignée
de parlementaires cette députée et cette
sénateurs vont se réunir mercredi en CMP
commission mixte paritaire pour tenter
d'arriver à un texte commun à première
vue pas de suspense sur les 14 membres
de la CMP disent sont favorables au
projet et les tractations déjà
commencées
il y a déjà une volonté commune
d'arriver à une commission mix paritaire
conclusive donc ça permet déjà de
ensuite la difficulté particulière c'est
que il n'y a pas de marqueur Assemblée
nationale puisque les députés ont été
empêchés de débattre et de voter en
conséquence on travaille sur le texte du
Sénat mais il y aura tout de même
négociation car à droite députés et
sénateurs ne sont pas complètement sur
la même ligne principale des accords les
carrières longues les députés et leurs
veulent permettre à tous ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler jeune de partir
après 43 années de cotisations
trop coûteux pour la majorité
sénatoriale le Sénat ne changera pas de
position
tout simplement parce que nous avons eu
beaucoup de concessions en la matière de
la part du gouvernement ça n'est jamais
assez c'est vrai mais d'un autre côté il
faut qu'il y a un équilibre financier si
à force de concession de modification du
texte on finit par ne pas avoir de gains
financiers pour l'équilibre des
retraites ça ne sert à rien de faire une
réforme donc on a obtenu un certain
nombre de choses au Sénat pour nous nous
en restons là de quoi braquer certains
députés de droite hostiles à la réforme
qui ont fait des carrières longues une
véritable ligne rouge le patron des
députés LR rabot affirmé que son groupe
votre a majoritairement le texte ses
troupes restent divisés sur le sujet
[Musique]
réfléchissent encore entre le contre
l'abstention des gens qui sont
réfléchissent entre l'abstention et de
pour et qui attendront de savoir quelle
taille ce sera de la de la semaine très
clairement il y a une majorité naître au
sein de notre groupe pour voter cette
cette réforme 15 à 20 députés de droite
seraient contre ou encore indécis sur
leur vote des voies qui pourraient
manquer au gouvernement pour faire ôter
sa réforme des retraites par l'Assemblée
nationale
et ça discute déjà pendant le sujet de
Samia Dechy et je vous présente donc mes
invités qui sont pressés de
débattreina bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
constitutionnaliste et mettre le
conférences en droit public Jean
garrigue bonsoir bienvenue à vous
historien président du Comité d'histoire
parlementaire et vous publiez Élisée
contre Matignon le couple infernal de
1958 à nos jours c'est publié chez aux
éditions Talandier Nathalie second
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
éditorialiste à l'opinion et Emily
bonsoir Émilie bienvenue à vous vous
êtes spécialiste en communication
politique et éditorialiste pour sens
publique uncharden visionnage commence
avec vous cette commission mixte
paritaire est-ce qu'elle est inédite
pour ne pas dire historique
beaucoup d'égards alors la Commission
mixparitaire en tant que telle pas
tellement puisque en réalité c'est un
procédure procédure très courante sous
la Cinquième République il faut savoir
que en temps normal c'est après deux
lectures qu'on peut donc solliciter
cette CMP pour concilier et en tant de
procédure accélérée c'est au bout d'une
seule lecture mais donc la CMP elle a
l'habitude d'arriver quand les choses
sont déjà jouées en réalité
c'est que ça a pas été voté parce que
déjà par rapport à son champ de
compétence normalement il travaille sur
trois à quatre à cinq articles qui
restent encore en débat mais il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont déjà été
avalisées par le Sénat et l'Assemblée
qui se sont mis en accord ici c'est pas
possible étant donné que l'Assemblée
nationale n'a même pas voté donc de
toute façon la CMP un champ de
compétence sur l'intégralité du texte
elle va devoir proposer elle-même le
seul texte en fait sur lequel un
compromis aura été trouvé entre député
et sénateurs donc oui elle est inédite
l'ambiance aussi doit être tout à fait
différent des ambiances feutrée connaît
la CMP ou tout a été devenu mais où on
arrive à travailler finalement dans dans
une entente relativement cordiale ici
les positions sont fermes on voit bien
que de toute façon même s'il y a des
majorités qui se dégagent assez
clairement dans la CMP on les attend au
tournant donc oui une CMP tout à fait
historique pour son style pour son champ
de compétence et pour beaucoup de choses
la commission xper tous les médias en
parlent on est évidemment pas avec cette
réforme des retraites vous diriez que
les Français
réapprennent un peu le fonctionnement
nos institutions parlementaires ce qui
est plutôt une bonne nouvelle bon ça
redonne pas pour autant un grand souffle
à notre bonne vieille Cinquième
République nous nous emballons pas oui
mais vous avez raison il y a quelque
part un parfum de pédagogie
parlementaire rien que de voir ce
l'engouement des mènent des médias sur
ce surtout surtout de ces questions sur
les règlements on a beaucoup parlé des
règlements du Sénat mais votre bloqué
des évidemment du 49 3 oui il y a une
vraie si on devait tirer des aspects
positifs de cette crise il y en a pas
beaucoup je pense que là cette voilà
cette meilleure connaissance des des
rouages de la vie parlementaire ça ça en
fait partie et peut-être aussi à la
faveur de ce qui vient de se passer et
parce que nous sommes au Sénat une forme
de réhabilitation de ce qu'est la vie
parlementaire au Sénat spécifiquement et
l'utilité d'une chambre haute ou d'une
deuxième chambre parce que ce qui s'est
passé c'est quand même malgré tout que
au moins le Sénat ils sont allés au bout
du vote je sais pas s'ils ont bien fait
ou mal fait mais enfin ils sont quand
même olé au bout de au bout de la loi et
ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'ailleurs qui va servir de base c'est
quand même un paradoxe que c'est ça qui
va servir de base à la discussion de la
CMPP de l'ordinaire c'est plutôt le
contraire Nathalie sogone est-ce que il
peut y avoir des surprises dans cette
commission experitaire sur sur le
contenu du texte et dire est-ce que
voilà on peut voir sortir de de cette
journée de de débat à huis clos on va y
revenir sur la notion de de huis clos on
peut on peut voir le texte évolué alors
oui forcément parce que il y a des il y
a des points de de contact enfin il y a
des points qui sont qui sont par accord
entre LR et la majorité Renaissance
notamment le CDI senior ils sont obligés
de trouver un compromis et ils y sont
ils sont en train d'y travailler les
tractations elles se jouent maintenant
ça se joue maintenant plutôt que en CMP
demain
il y a peut-être aussi un peu de
friction entre entre LR alors entre
sénateur et députés
sur les 43 annuités pour les carrières
longues le c'est une introduction du
députés LR sous la pression de
d'Aurélien Pradier les sénateurs sont
pas tellement sur cette ligne en réalité
ils vont pas se battre pour vous avez vu
ce qu'a dit on n'est pas le Savary sur
les les 43eités c'est plus des carrières
longues si on les donne à tout le monde
donc ils sont on voit qu'ils sont pas
sur la même ligne et au milieu il y a le
ya Renaissance enfin il y a la majorité
qui va essayer quand même de trouver un
compromis elles non plus n'est pas
favorable parce que c'est c'est si on
fait les 43 années d'unités pour tout le
monde c'est la disparition de l'âge
légal donc effectivement mais ça ça se
joue avant si j'ose dire la CMP ils sont
quand même ils vont pas le faire devant
devant l'opposition donc voilà et ce
sont les points un peu durs de cette
réunion il y a vraiment de l'enjeu dans
la journée de demain Émilie oui il y a
de l'enjeu c'est intéressant de voir les
Français s'approprier toutes ces toutes
ces outils on a vu aussi au Sénat tout
ce qui s'est passé on a eu l'impression
que les Français connaissaient sur le
bout des doigts finalement ne nous
emballons pas mais mais il y a un
progrès il y a un problème progrès il y
a un appétit aussi j'ai l'impression
pour tout ça mais à côté de ça on sent
quand même même s'il y a encore des
décisions à venir que c'est quand même
le cadre il est donné il est très
restreint on est quand même sur une
réforme qui a un sens depuis le début
qui est quand même compartimenté avec ce
fameux âge à 64 ans donc le report de
l'âge légal ça bouge pas donc si ça
bouge c'est globalement pas des petites
choses parce que ça va être des
améliorations sur aussi des erreurs il y
a eu des erreurs dans le texte de base
et donc c'est des améliorations mais
globalement il y a pas que des Français
excuser expriment dans la rue et par la
mobilisation c'est à dire une recherche
un petit peu une réflexion beaucoup plus
de fond sur ce que ça représente ce
projet pour la société pour les Français
et les Françaises à l'avenir il y a pas
tout ça donc c'est c'est un peu tactique
pour qu'il y ait un vote mais c'est un
petit peu à côté de cette réflexion plus
sociétale on va dire alors on va rester
sur on imagine être des petites souris
dans la Commission on propose je vais
proposer tout ça Quentin calmer de nous
rejoindre vous n'êtes pas la petite
souris Quentin évidemment bonsoir
bienvenue à vous comment ça va se passer
demain donc ça démarre à 9h à
l'Assemblée voilà et c'est vrai que on
le voit autour de ce plateau et il est
rare qui est autant d'enjeux autour
d'une commission esparita donc on va
rappeler les les les enjeux une
commission d'expéritaire c'est donc la
réunion de 7 députés cette sénateurs qui
se réunissent effectivement à huit clos
pour trouver un accord quand il y a deux
versions différentes d'un même texte
d'un même projet de loi il y a donc 14
parlementaires qui votent et essaie de
se mettre d'accord et je rajouterais par
rapport au sujet de semi-2h qu'on a les
noms de ces parlementaires et il
s'affiche parce que ces députés c'est
sénateurs et bien ils sont choisis
proportionnellement aux équilibres de
chacune des deux chambres équilibres
politiques et ce que l'on note c'est
quand les dissonant les députés la
majorité présidentielle Renaissance et
modem que l'on voit en orange avec les
parlementaires LR et centriste et bien
on obtient un mécaniquement 10 voix sur
14 membres donc la majorité
présidentielle et sénatoriale peut
négocier dans cette réunion et à E10 ils
peuvent écrire la réforme de retraite
qui serait acceptable pour les deux
camps alors dans ce contexte c'est là
que on reparle du huis clos la gauche a
demandé que les débats soient publics
exactement c'était la demande du chef de
fil des députés PS Boris Vallot il a
écrit à la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale au nom de l'exigence de clarté
de sincérité de transparence des débats
parlementaires a-t-il écrit les députés
socialistes formulent la demande que la
Conférence des Présidents puisse
exceptionnellement se prononcer sur la
publicité des travaux de la commission
mix paritaire dans la matinée la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale lui
a répondu par la négative regardez la
publicité des travaux de la commission
est assuré seulement par un compte rendu
écrit qui fait état des travaux et des
votes en commission ainsi que des inter
ventions prononcées devant elle à
l'exclusion de tout autre procédé il est
vrai c'est déjà le cas qu'il existe un
compte rendu écrit des échanges en CMP
mais il est publié un posteriori
plusieurs fois plusieurs jours enfin
souvent plusieurs jours après la réunion
et avant même ce refus de pivel la chef
de fil des insoumis Mathilde panneaux a
fait savoir que elle ferait fuiter les
échanges voilà elle l'a dit c'était sur
notre antenne hier soir je propose de
l'écouter
la commission pour que vous puissiez la
suivre nous sortirons régulièrement et
vous nous rappeler en fait comprenez que
quand le débat pourquoi est-ce que le
débat est publique à l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat par ailleurs c'est
parce que chacun et chacune peut alors
suivre les débats et donc je trouve
intéressant dans un moment où ce texte
n'a pas été discuté dans beaucoup des
aspects je trouve intéressant que les
citoyens la suite de la commission
donc c'est à dire une publication des
échanges en direct sur l'application
Twitter ce qui va sans doute énerver
passablement les autres parlementaires
présents à la CMP l'idée étant bien sûr
pour les insoumis de mettre la pression
sur les autres membres de cette réunion
Tom merci beaucoup Quentin c'était très
clair uncharen beezina que risque
imaginons que ce que vient nous décrire
quand un se passe rien que risque a-t-il
panneau ou ou ceux qui live tout le
trait pardon de l'anglicisme en tout cas
qui publierait en direct les les débats
le contenu de cette commission
disparitaire alors on a un précédent sur
cette législature alors je reste plus
quel réseau exactement cela concerne
mais un député qui justement avait voulu
un député France insoumise avait voulu
pendant les séances justement faire
du live en fait c'est à dire tout
simplement montrer ce qui se passait
réellement pour notamment acter un peu
de sa prise de c'était surtout twitch
acté de sa prise de parole et il a écopé
d'un rappel oralement par la présidente
alors ce qui est pas une énorme sanction
néanmoins ça prouve quand même que le
règlement c'est le règlement et à partir
du moment où au miel Brown televé campe
sur les deux articles du règlement qui
précisent bien que c'est seulement le
compte rendu écrit qui doit sortir de la
CMP on voit mal comment un autre média
pour être tout à coup intervenir dans je
vais vous poser la question mais
peut-être genre vous pouvez commencer et
pourquoi pas
prenons prenons finalement le les
parlementaires de gauche au mot pourquoi
pas pourquoi pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
le diffuser question les arguments pour
le biclo c'est une question très
intéressante en réalité parce que on est
au croisement entre l'égalité et
légitimité je veux dire que la légalité
en l'occurrence est respectée l'usage et
se dire que il y a effectivement des
discussions qui n'ont pas à être perçues
par le plus grand nombre parce que
chaque parlementaire doit aussi garder
une forme d'autonomie et d'indépendance
et ça c'est depuis la Révolution
française par rapport à ces moments
c'est quelque chose de très important
dans l'esprit des parlementaires mais la
légitimité démocratique au sens où elle
est perçue maintenant c'est à dire qu'il
y a une exigence de transparence
démocratique qui qu'on voit pointe dans
la société et à la faveur de cette crise
au combien puisqu'on reproche beaucoup à
tous ce processus toute la mécanique
actuelle de ne pas être véritablement
démocratique et puis le huis clos
alimente une forme de soupçon une forme
de soupçon donc on est vraiment là à la
croisée à la croisée des chemins
honnêtement moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas de
réponse c'est si je répondais à la
demande sociale je dirais oui c'est bien
que que ça puisse être public comme
maintenant d'ailleurs tous les débats
sont publics télévisés etc et peut-être
qu'il faudrait pas réfléchir à une
réforme du règlement de désassemblées
qui pourraient aller vers cette
transparence mais je le répète
n'oublions pas malgré tout ce principe
essentiel de cette autonomie du
parlementaire par rapport au monde
c'est-à-dire par rapport à l'opinion
publique ça peut être important dans
certains dans certains domaines
c'est-à-dire de savoir que vous n'êtes
pas sous le sous le regard sous la
pression de des élèves un mot là dessus
dans la ligne
c'est pas possible mais la seule chose
c'est vraiment de dire et et c'est un
rattachement historique aussi par
rapport à 58 la CMP c'est un organe très
particulier qui a été très peu
réglementé en réalité il n'a même pas
elle apparaît très peu dans les
règlements d'assemblée il y a tout juste
une instruction en fait de 59 qui régit
les règles de vote comment ça se passe
etc et ça n'est pas anodin il y a une
raison à cela par rapport au fait que
c'est un organe de pacification qu'on
n'avait pas tellement d'ailleurs sous
les républiques précédentes ça existait
sous d'autres formes mais cette CMP on a
voulu lui laisser le champ libre pour
arriver à organiser le bicaméralisme et
donc peut-être une petite dose de
secrets peut parfois aussi permettre
d'avoir des accords qui publiquement ne
passeraient pas ça c'est très
intéressant parce que vous dites
pacification or la ligne de LFI c'est
conflictualité donc forcément ça ne peut
pas aller ensemble je voulais juste
rappeler que jusqu'au début des années
2000 le travail en commission dans les
commissions parlementaires n'étaient pas
filmées n'étaient pas publique et il a
été rendu public sous enfin c'est les
commissions d'enquête et notamment la
commission Outreau qui a été filmée qui
ont ouvert ça qui ont fait progresser la
transparence des débats à l'Assemblée
donc le sens de l'histoire
le sens de l'histoire c'est quand même
d'aller vers la publicité des débats
d'autant plus que on le sait ça ne se
passe pas là c'est pas là que que sont
réellement faites les transactions en
réalité puisqu'il vaillent ensuite un
compte rendu qui est ça s'appelle c'est
ça la complicité mais vous voulez dire
la publicité écrite le lendemain bon
voilà je voulais rester voir ici
donc après cette commission mixte
paritaire évidemment la journée de jeudi
elle sera décisive le vote à l'Assemblée
nationale qui va se jouer à quelques
voies près si si le gouvernement
Élisabeth borde décide de ne pas
utiliser le 49-3 les députés hésitants
sont courtisées regardez ce que dit
Jean-Luc Bourgeaud qui est député
rattaché LR dit les vilaine on a essayé
de me dire que si je changeais d'avis il
pourrait y avoir un autre regard sur les
dossiers de mon territoire par exemple
sur le nouvel hôpital de Saint-Malo et
ce témoignage le chef des députés et
Olivier Marleix préfère y voir plutôt de
l'humour que des pressions on l'écoute
non non je crois que personne n'a fait
tas de pression il y a un député qui a
dit que que le gouvernement était
était
avait l'air d'être très très à l'écoute
de faire des avances ouais il y en a un
qui voilà c'est un témoignage qui te dit
d'ailleurs plutôt sur le temps de faire
un tour assez humoristique pour avoir
écouté son propos et il y a pas de il y
a pas de pression je pense que le
gouvernement d'ailleurs est parfaitement
conscient que si le tentait à la moindre
pression serait un effet contraire sur
les députés alors aux États-Unis les les
parlementaires ils ont l'habitude de de
ces tractations presque de monnayer leur
vote au profit de leur territoire en
France ça me semble business c'est quoi
c'est un peu un tabou alors ça dépend de
quelle pression on parle si on parle
d'une pression gouvernementale ni les
États-Unis ni aucun régime parlementaire
ne pourrait vraiment admettre ce type de
chantage même si au fond financièrement
parfois malheureusement et on peut
parler aussi des territoires ça existe
un peu la reprise financière est-ce que
c'est un tabou de savoir si oui ou non
on est vraiment libre de son vote en
France oui c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui fait pas partie de notre
culture on a un peu cette tradition
historique de dire justement que le vote
doit être absolument libre que quiconque
doit écouter ses instincts sonirisme le
premier député auquel on pense ça va
être la Martine c'est chose là mais
pourtant oui dépression du territoire
existent évidemment des arbitrages d'un
côté et de l'autre doivent être fait et
il est vrai au parlementaire je pense
que c'est le point qu'il faut rappeler
dans ton temps assez peu parler dans
dans cette discussion pourtant c'est que
la discipline de groupe a une existence
par contre historique dans les
parlements français et surtout sous la
Cinquième République donc qu'il y ait
une discipline du groupe pour voter ou
en tout cas un appel des présidents de
groupe à essayer d'avoir un vote plutôt
unanime sur une question ne me paraît
pas être quelque chose qui soit
complètement contraire à notre pratique
tout le monde fait ses comptes Nathalie
sogone évidemment alors il y a le le
nombre de députés LR mais il y a aussi
au sein de la majorité on n'est pas
froid qu'il y a quoi deux députés
horizons par exemple trois
trois députés horizons il y a quatre
cinq députés Renaissance
alors on me dit ce soir que le député
l'unique député MoDem qui voulait voter
contre et c'est ravisé Richard Amos et
il est rentré dans le rang il va voter
pour enfin ce qui est rare enfin là on
en est un point où ils font le
gouvernement la majorité procède
individualité par individualité
c'est-à-dire que quand vous parliez de
la discipline de groupe avec LR ça
n'existe plus c'est à dire que
l'effondrement de ce parti est tel que
le président du parti les présidents de
groupe sont incapables d'imposer une
ligne à leur députés et que la majorité
est obligée de faire individualité par
individualité pour aller chercher les
voix c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire aujourd'hui je voulais juste
rappeler quand même dans l'histoire que
à l'époque de
Michel Rocard et de des utilisations
récurrentes du 49-3 il faisait ça auprès
des domiens des députés d'outre-mer
on leur promettait une école il y avait
il y avait l'hôpital du Carcassonne
parce que c'était le conseiller de
Michel Rocard le constitutionnaliste qui
était chargé de ce travail là je sais
pas si quelqu'un fait ce travail là
aujourd'hui dans le gouvernement
d'Elisabeth borne mais
je j'ai cru comprendre que ça se passait
encore c'est à dire que ça veut dire que
ce sont enfin
séparés les lesages en disant toi tu
appelles tel député enfin vous voyez ce
que je veux dire les ministres les
responsables de la majorité ils se sont
répartis le travail effectivement
je reviens moi je pense que ça montre un
effet une faiblesse à la fois chez les
républicains parce que on voit bien
qu'il y a pas de tenue du groupe mais
aussi au niveau de la majorité
souvenez-vous quand même on parlait
d'une maison commune avec horizon avec
le Modem et en fait on voit que ça
n'existe pas et qu'il faut aller
individuellement aller convaincre les
uns et les autres donc il y a quand même
un manque de structuration de cette
fameuse majorité
je vais vous laisser développer mais je
me dis quelle marque il faut en nombre
députés à Elisabeth borne pour prendre
le risque en disant il peut y avoir des
défections derrière une minute c'est
quoi c'est 10 d'avant je pense oui parce
que ce silence ce serait trop juste mais
il faut compter si je ne m'amuse le vote
se fera sur les suffrages exprimé donc
il y a aussi les absences et il paraît
que c'est aussi un enjeu très très fort
actuellement oui parce que détracteurs
qui veut pas voter contre mais qui veut
il va avoir piscine quoi je veux dire
parce que là les députés ils sont pris
entre entre le marteau et l'enclume le
marteau c'est c'est de se dire bah je
dois respecter la discipline de groupe
sinon il y aura des représailles parce
que ça existe des représailles y compris
ce nom de l'exécutif mais l'enclume
c'est de se dire bah si je si on sait
que je j'ai voté ce projet mes électeurs
ils vont pas être très très contents
parce que la majorité des Français sont
compte donc il y a vraiment un travail
là de de j'allais dire de de micro de
micro de dentelle il y a le ministre
chargé des Relations avec le Parlement
Franck Riester qui a quand même dans un
premier temps qui a dû être chargé de de
faire ça et pour revenir à Michel Rocard
c'est pas c'est pas si nouveau mais vous
l'avez dit Guy Carcassonne il allait
voir député par députés à l'époque quand
ils avaient cette fameuse majorité
stéréo tantôt je m'appuie sur les
communistes tantôt je m'appuie sur le
centre de gauche centre droit et il
faisait ça aussi aux petits points et
j'ajouterai une dernière chose parce que
quand même je suis historien les groupes
parlementaires c'est pas quelque chose
qui a toujours existé sous la vie
politique française c'est sa date du
début du 20e siècle l'influence des
groupes donc la discipline de groupe
c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
est logiquement si vous voulez dans le
l'esprit initial de la vie parlementaire
chaque député est libre de son choix
donc cette discipline de groupe c'est ce
que on demande aujourd'hui enfin c'est
ce qui est nécessité par le l'exécutif
mais c'est pas forcément une règle on va
parler des d'Emmanuel Macron dans un
instant mais Nathalie seconde je disais
en titre journée décisive pour pour
notamment pour Elisabeth borne est-ce
qu'elle joue forcément son avenir à
Matignon là dans les 48 heures qui
viennent
alors d'une certaine façon oui parce que
je pense que enfin ça a beaucoup évolué
ces derniers jours l'Élysée laissait
entendre il y a la semaine dernière
encore que si ça passait qu'aux 49-3
sont postés en jeu
parce qu'elle aurait pas réussi à
convaincre à trouver à bâtir une
majorité parce que c'était la seule la
mission qu'il avait donné Emmanuel
Macron c'est de construire une majorité
sur cette réforme et que donc forcément
il y aurait des conséquences et qui
pourrait y avoir un remaniement
aujourd'hui on dit qu'on en est plus là
que l'essentiel c'est que le texte passe
49-3 ou vote et que elle sauvera il la
gardera en tout cas dans un premier
temps mais évidemment si c'est au 49-3
elle a tellement dit et redit qu'elle
vous elle voulait pas passer par le 29 3
je veux éviter le 40 bien sûr alors
maintenant on nous dit que c'est une
tactique mais enfin elle l'a tellement
répété que
apparaîtra si c'est au 49-3 comme un
affaiblissement pour elle
après je peux pas prévoir mais elle sera
affaiblie par cette affaire alors signe
du caractère décisif des heures qui
viennent Emmanuel Macron c'est invité à
la réunion hebdomadaire de coordination
des cadres du camp présidentiel Émilie
le pré dans la République veut pas peser
dans la dernière ligne droite c'est le
retour parce que ça faisait un moment
qui nous parlait plutôt de loin des
Pays-Bas d'Afrique avec des messages
évasifs justement sur la réforme des
retraites et là il se pointe directement
donc dans une des réunions hebdomadaires
comme je vous disiez des cadres de la
majorité en général
c'était hier qu'est-ce qu'il a déclaré
nous avons une majorité solide alors
assez surprenant par le temps qui court
et ce qu'on disait à l'instant surtout
que les membres de son équipe sont
plutôt collés à la calculette en train
de compter les voix côté majorité côté
républicain comment disait quelle
méthode utilise Emmanuel Macron alors il
en appelle à la responsabilité de
l'opposition alors il faut comprendre ça
serait incohérent de ne pas voter une
réforme qui est Jésus par votre partie
et qui a été modifié au Sénat selon vos
demandes ou presque Macron il en remet
aussi une couche sur la nécessité
absolue de la réforme pour je le cite le
financement de nos retraites et la
solidité du pays alors heureusement il
est pas allé jusqu'à invoquer les
risques sur le réchauffement climatique
ou la santé des enfants vous voyez de
qui je veux parler mais les députés les
républicains qui restent remontés contre
la réforme trouve d'autres façons de s'y
opposer en cas de 49,3 certains se
disent prêts à faire tomber le
gouvernement en s'alliant et on en
parlait tout à l'heure des DOM-TOM en
saluant au groupe liberté indépendant
outre-mer et territoires liotte dans une
motion de censure transpartisanes la
raison qui serait invoquée ça serait un
déni de démocratie c'est l'argument qui
est défendu par Charles de Courson qui
est député l'iode de la Marne il était
interrogé ce matin sur BFM TV
tennis démocratie sociale à l'égard des
partenaires sociaux dont on a besoin
pour gérer ce pays mais déni de
démocratie à l'égard du Parlement car
avoir utilisé une loi rectificative de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
en fait empêcher un vrai débat en
limitant à 20 jours l'Assemblée
nationale 15 jours le Sénat et 15 jours
en vote définitif c'est un détournement
total de procédure d'ailleurs on ira son
expliqué au Conseil constitutionnel mais
alors quoi qu'il en soit le président de
la République joue son va tout est-ce
que c'est le bon moment à ce moment et
bien choisi pour intervenir oui c'est un
moment important on l'a dit injuste
avant la commission mix paritaire qui se
tient demain mais surtout juste après la
mobilisation de samedi qui était un peu
à la baisse ces ministres bien éduqué
reprennent en cœur cette méthode Coué
nous souhaitons transformer notre
majorité relative en majorité absolue
insiste Olivier Véran le porte-parole
nous sommes convaincus qu'il y a une
majorité sur ce texte répond en écho
Olivier du simple ministre du Travail
alors Emmanuel Macron transformé cet
essai jeudi avec un vote sans le fameux
Joker 49.3 on pourrait dire que c'est
une petite victoire mais il faudrait
quand même que la mobilisation d'ici là
alors on en reparlera de la de ce que
peut faire l'intercy à la partie de
jeudi soir Nathalie je reviens vers vous
parce que vous suivez
Emmanuel Macron
j'ai essayé oui c'est pas toujours
facile en tout cas vous êtes en contact
à l'Elysée évidemment c'est quoi l'état
d'esprit voudrait passer à autre chose
passer à d'autres formes c'est vraiment
ça quoi oui c'est vraiment que ça soit
derrière lui et qu'il puisse tout de
suite passer à autre chose enfin c'est
c'est un mauvais moment à passer pour
lui je pense enfin c'est ce que c'est ce
que disent ceux qui le qu'il voit qui
qui discute avec lui mais il veut
surtout tourner là-bas j'ai d'ailleurs
on voit bien que toute la communication
de l'Elysée depuis
ces dernières quatre dernières semaines
c'est et l'après qu'est-ce qui va se
passer après c'est à dire qu'ils
orientent ils orientent les papiers dans
les journaux sur sur la pré alors qu'on
est même au coeur d'une bataille
décisive pour son quinquennat dont il a
fait lui-même la mère des batailles et
effectivement il a voilà ça ne peut que
passer pour lui
qu'il a choisi de de laisser Isabelle
borne ça permet en première ligne sur
pour alors je le cite pour respecter le
temps parlementaire ça c'est le
l'argument officiel il y en a un autre
il aurait peut-être Christ il sait qu'il
aurait cristallisé les oppositions
autour d'eux de lui si c'était engagé un
peu plus c'est peut-être même déjà le
cas puisque si vous écoutez le message
de la rue il va tellement hostile à
Elisabeth borne mais à Emmanuel Macron
ça aurait encore plus peut-être
cristallisé l'opposition encore une fois
je je crois qu'on est dans le partage
traditionnel de la Cinquième République
genre évidemment sera forcément de mon
avis le pas toujours moi c'est très bien
alors très bien voilà on va pouvoir en
discuter mais je crois vraiment que le
premier ministre a quand même ce rôle de
prendre les balles et que le Président
de la République n'est jamais vraiment
le premier rideau sur une réforme de
cette ampleur
[Musique]
au salon de l'agriculture je devrais
donner le cap moi-même mais voilà
affaire à suivre mais quand même
j'engage il n'y a pas eu de prise de
parole solennelle du président de la
République sur cette réforme des
retraites depuis plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois
déminé la critique que je voulais faire
qu'une critique feutrée mais justement
moi ce que je trouve par rapport au
conflit précédent notamment autour de la
réforme des retraites c'est que le
président a été beaucoup plus présent
que nous l'ont été ces prédécesseurs
souvenons-nous de du conflit de 1995
Jacques Chirac est totalement en retrait
c'est Alain Juppé qui porte tout y
compris les chèques final le retrait de
la loi parce que Jacques Chirac d'abord
il était assez hostile au départ sous
pression des régimes spéciaux et qui lui
tape sur les doigts quand quand les
choses se sont gâtées donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que précisément
ça qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
assisté à cette dérive pas le premier à
le dire dérive présidentialiste de la
Cinquième République et que dans ce
conflit il y a effectivement ce qui va
ce qui va se passer et ce qui se ce que
disait une Charlène c'est que tout
remonte au président de la République
moi j'ai l'impression que les Français
ne sont pas tellement en colère contre
Elisabeth borne mais c'est autour de
tout ce cristallise autour de du
président de la République preuve en
elle l'invitation la demande des
syndicats d'une rencontre qu'il a
d'ailleurs refusé donc moi je pense
qu'il y a vraiment quelque chose qui se
joue là autour de la personne de du
président et que cette crise là au fond
elle n'est que le l'aboutissement de
tout un processus moi je le dis depuis
le début d'ailleurs depuis le début de
cette crise l'aboutissement de tout un
processus visant à montrer un président
qui ne comprend pas la manière dont il
faut gouverner sur la 5ème République et
que ne comprend pas ce qu'est le
mouvement social sous la Cinquième
République ça c'est quelque chose qui
est qui qui monte très très fort et qui
montre bien que la situation de de
d'Elizabeth borne n'est pas la même que
celle de ses prédécesseurs
au-delà de la personnalisation qui a
effectué Emmanuel Macron c'est les
objectifs c'est la difficulté à défendre
des objectifs crédibles en fait pour
cette réforme parce que au tout début
souvenez-vous c'était pour financer la
transition écologique la santé après on
a dit non non c'est pour équilibrer
vraiment notre régime de retraite après
on a dit ah ben non c'est pour de la
justice sociale puis on s'est rendu
compte que ça tenait pas la route on est
revenu sur l'équilibre financier en
disant ben c'est indispensable parce que
sinon c'est la faillite du régime de
retraite par répartition et finalement
les Français ils comprennent bien que
c'est pas tenable que aucun de ses
objectifs finalement ne sont vraiment
tangibles et donc ils remettent en
question ça donc pourquoi faire une
réforme dont personne ne veut et qui
sert finalement à quoi à équilibrer un
tout petit peu quelque chose qui est pas
forcément indispensable il y a pas péril
en a demeure sur l'équilibre financier
alors bon certains ont tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord là-dessus
il y a des interrogations il y a des
interrogations là je suis d'accord avec
vous il nous reste un peu moins de 10
minutes on va maintenant consacrer un
chapitre à la stratégie de
l'intersydicale journée d'action et de
manifestation évidemment demain grève
qui continue jeudi tiens par exemple
pour bloquer
l'activité maritime des ports français à
écouter
pas faire long je crois que vous avez
compris qu'on est déterminé partout en
France dans tous les ports cette semaine
les ports seront arrêtés
72 heures journée pour mort jeudi donc
journée pour moi ça veut dire que toutes
les activités autour d'un port dans le
port il y a rien qui rentre il y a rien
qui sort
et je peux vous dire que ça fait mal
alors c'est assez disparate en fait
Nathalie sogone parce qu'il y a des
secteurs où c'est plutôt en train de
retomber on va dire RATP raffinerie en
schématisant puis là effectivement les
ports c'est un nouveau secteur qui
rentre dans dans le mouvement 9e journée
de manifestation de de mobilisation et
pourtant la réforme elle avance
inexorablement est-ce que on n'atteint
pas les limites de la stratégie
syndicale quand même
si forcément parce que d'un côté il y a
un parlement qui avance un texte qui va
être voté très probablement quel que
soit les circonstances et de l'autre il
y a un mouvement qui faiblit quand même
parce que et surtout ce qu'on observe
dans les sondages c'est que les Français
ont depuis le début intériorisé que
cette réforme passerait donc
deux tiers je crois des Français pensent
que elle sera adoptée stable donc
l'opposition à la réforme ce qui
soutiennent la réforme et ceux qui
disent de toute façon elle passera si
stable quoi c'est stable et en plus ceux
qui sont dans la rue ou qui des rêves et
même de monde qui font grève de moins en
moins d'ailleurs c'est ceux qui
bénéficient des régimes spéciaux quand
même c'est la SNCF c'est la RATP même si
on est en train de les supprimer ces
régimes et on voit pas c'est presque une
mobilisation de de est-ce qu'ils font
est-ce qu'ils font grève par procuration
pour ceux pour du privé qui mais en tout
cas le privé massivement n'y va pas ne
se mobilise pas et
et on sent moi ce que j'entends c'est
une lassitude de ces gens qui qui
bénéficient des régimes spéciaux se
mobiliser pour finalement un texte qui
les touche de très loin et c'est bien la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs le
gouvernement n'a pas n'a pas accéléré
comme le souhaitait Bruno Retailleau la
fin des régimes sociaux mais si on au
delà des 48 heures à venir un chiant se
pose la question de de la démocratie
sociale du dialogue social de la
démocratie sociale
moi j'ai quand même le sentiment que ce
que cette séquence ce conflit va laisser
des traces et peut-être d'ailleurs
fragiliser la capacité d'Emmanuel Macron
à réformer dans les prochains dans les
prochains mois vous voyez ce que je veux
dire le lien est tellement distendu pour
ne pas dire rompu avec les syndicats
notamment la CFDT que ça va être un peu
difficile de faire venir des gens à la
table des négociations pour les
prochaines réformes il faut on se
projette sur l'après et je vous rejoins
largement mais il faut aussi repenser à
l'avant c'est quand même le point faible
de cette présidence de de ce premier
mandat aussi on avait parlé d'un
président qui négligeait les corps
intermédiaires il avait annoncé une
nouvelle méthode pour être réélu ça fait
partie de son discours d'investiture et
pourtant cette nouvelle méthode alors on
racontera que le Conseil national de la
refondation était censé jouer ce rôle
que certains syndicats y sont allés
entraînant des pieds d'autres ayant
refusé mais ça prouve bien qu'en fait le
divorce est acté depuis assez longtemps
évidemment ça restera le point fort de
cette point faible de cette présidence
j'ajoute d'ailleurs que il y a un peu
une stratégie du 1+4 ou du 4 + 1 dans
les quinquennat c'est à dire de se dire
bon la première première année on fait
les choses les plus difficiles et puis
après quitte à rester dans l'attentisme
et bien ça ira surtout sur les deuxième
mandat ou au contraire essayer de se
dire et bien je vais essayer de
capitaliser pour bien réunir majorité au
départ et puis c'est à la fin que ça
sera plus difficile François Hollande
par exemple a en fait vécu plutôt un cas
de plus un plutôt qu'un plus 4 que
Emmanuel Macron anticipe et on sait bien
rendu compte de la difficulté qu'il a eu
ensuite à finalement ressortir la tête
de l'eau après l'attaque des frondeurs
après finalement la véritable
fragilisation de son mandat donc ici en
attaquant par cette fragilisation on se
demande bien à quoi vont ressembler les
quatre prochaines années est-ce qu'un
président va devenir un président de
l'Assemblée de l'Internationale avec
cette idée du domaine réservé il y a
beaucoup de questions qui à mon avis se
posent autour de cette personnalité
c'est la première fois qu'on a un
président réélu en quinquennat donc
c'est aussi un nouveau cas de figure
c'est pour tous les prétendants sachant
que lui ne peut pas se représenter et
donc même pour tous les autres enfin
c'est c'est une nouvelle
fois avec ça moi je me pose la question
aussi
de cette de ce mouvement social qui
peut-être n'a pas trouvé d'écho au sein
de l'Assemblée ou en tout cas pas de la
façon dont il le souhaitait parce que
comme le disait Jean Garry il y a
beaucoup de critiques sur la politique
sociale et économique que mène Emmanuel
Macron et peut-être certains espérer
dans la news ou dans en tout cas cette
forme de gauche à voir une résonance
pour porter d'autres idées et en fait la
façon dont la nuit pèse la portée n'a
pas abouti et quelque part ces
espérances
et pas tellement sur le fond pas pu
discuter et peut-être que justement ce
mouvement social ne trouve pas d'issue
politique d'une manière raisonnable et
les syndicats ne permettent pas ces
discussions au sein de l'assemblée donc
ça c'est peut-être aussi à construire à
gauche peut-être autrement mais bon ça
c'est un espoir peut-être réalisable
mais il va falloir du travail sauf qu'il
y a une famille politique qui tire les
marrons du feu aussi parce que c'est il
faut rappeler quand même que le
rassemblement national c'est le premier
parti populaire premier parti ouvrier et
c'est un parti qui est une fois de plus
a joué très habilement sa partie dans la
crise parlementaire qu'on a vécu c'est à
dire qu'à jouer le jeu d'une opposition
mais d'une opposition régulière qui
était pas dans la conflictualité
systématique qui restait dans son dans
son coin et puis qui mais qui
manifestait l'opposition ferme au projet
du côté de du peuple et moi j'ai très
peur enfin j'ai très peur je
j'estime que manifestement c'est plutôt
cette famille là qui risque de tirer des
les marrons du feu parce que de toute
façon du côté d'Emmanuel Macron c'est un
échec c'est un échec par rapport à
justement à cette démocratie sociale
dont on parlait tout à l'heure et ça et
c'est un échec qui rejaillit aussi sur
l'ensemble de la classe politique parce
que c'est l'échec de des élites des
élites parlementaires qui vont risque de
voter la loi à moins que ça soit le 49-3
mais ce sera l'échec donc de la classe
politique confrontée au peuple et
qu'est-ce qui joue cette carte là du
peuple contre les élites c'est le
rassemblement national hier on en
parlait dans l'un de nos débats il y a
une quand on regarde la sociologie des
électeurs du rassemblement national et
la sociologie de ceux qui sont
majoritairement opposés à la réforme
effectivement il y a il y a des il y a
des croisements et des similitudes
importantes vous disiez échec mais quand
même si cette réforme est votée et là je
reviens un peu à l'état d'esprit de
l'exécutif il pourront se targuer d'une
victoire peut-être une petite victoire
si vous disiez tout à l'heure mais quand
même bien sûr non mais il manqueront pas
je voulais juste rajouter sur quand même
il y a un point fondamental dans ce
quinquennat et le précédent c'est
qu'Emmanuel Macron on le sait depuis le
début
ne crois pas à la légitimité des
syndicats des forces syndicales ils
l'estime qu'ils ne sont pas
représentatives il estime qu'ils n'ont
pas à intervenir sur la politique
nationale qui doivent être au niveau des
branches au niveau des entreprises au
niveau de la pénétration
c'est quand même il pourrait changer
d'avis il ne croit pas en réalité à
cette démocratie sociale donc donc
finalement son comportement là est
totalement cohérent avec ces conditions
il l'a dit dans un livre qui est passé
aperçu en 2016
il n'y croit pas ils sont pas
représentatifs ils n'ont pas à pesé à
intervenir dans ce débat là donc il les
a maltraités on a rarement vu un
exécutif qui traite aussi mal les
syndicats et qu'il les méprisent et on
verra le résultat on verra qu'elle
conséquences à aura ça on aura sans
doute en berger dit déjà qu'il ne
reviendra pas à la fin que plus rien ne
sera ne sera comme avant
je n'en parle même pas mais on
manifestement il y a un contentieux
personnel entre ces deux hommes qui ne
qui ne s'aiment pas depuis le début
enfin qui ne sont incapables de se
mettre d'accord de s'entendre de se
parler c'est très dommage parce que là
c'est juste pour dire que la CFDT ce
serait éventuellement justement le le la
manière de renouer un contact avec le
politique c'est c'est le syndicat
réformiste par excellence et ce serait
justement là qu'il faudrait jouer la
carte des décors intermédiaires merci
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat je rappelle
Jean Gary le titre de votre livret
Élysée contre Matignon le couple
infernal qui est publié aux éditions
taland